your chance of dying in a bathtub is
about one in a million and so terrorism
is one in 3.5 million I am Nicholas be
with reason TV and today we're talking
about John Mueller and Mark G Stewart
authors of Terror security and money
balancing the risks benefits and costs
of Homeland Security mark John thanks
for talking to us in your book you
estimate that we've spent the US has
spent about a trillion dollars and
enhanced Homeland Security expenditure
since 2002 what has that money bought
most the money has gone in federal
expenditures and particularly with terms
of aviation security which is probably
totaled more than about 80 to 90 billion
dollars in expense and so that is the
machines for TSA see any case and
personnel all you know or the SIP stuff
and even even air marshals there's
something like three to four thousand
air marshals they cost more than 1
billion dollars per year round so that's
serious money now in the book your cost
benefit analysis says that we're not
getting what we pay for why aren't we
and is there is there anything that we
could do that would would give us what
we're paying for yeah it's not clear
that we need these enhance security
expenditures and possibly go back even
to 911 type expenditures potentially but
the main issue in the book is to apply
standard cost-benefit analyses to these
expenditures the same way DHS does for
natural hazards so the idea basically is
to apply these to terrorism and DHS
simply hasn't done so so I mean the DHS
will say okay what would a an earthquake
or a volcano erupting costs you know
what's the likelihood it happen
motivated the costs what if we do this
measure like Bill earthquake shelters
how much will reduce the risk and how
much will it cost and they don't do that
with Tara it's very simple it's
basically you know if you're going to
put in air marshals but you know how
much they cost and you try to estimate
the likelihood that they'll actually
prevent an attack i might reduce the
risk and the the probability that a
building tech and how bad the attack
will be why it was a fairly simple copy
of calculation to determine whether it's
cost effective or why don't
do that there may be politics it may be
just the hysteria after 911 in which
they're really anticipating to be
multiple 911 s and there are thousands
of al Qaeda operatives a loose and that
just carried over and so if you do this
analysis now frequently what happens is
you come to conclusion that we wasted
we've miss spent at any rate huge
amounts of money but well how do you how
do you reboot the argument that the
reason we haven't had a million
Mogadishu zor you know a thousand 911s
is precisely because of the money that
we spent yeah well is a pretty good
straightforward way of doing it what you
do is you try to cover it how many
attacks using standard analyses again
the scene we're not doing anything
fancier knew how many attacks would have
to have been deterred prevented
disrupted or protected against to
justify these kinds of expenditures
using standard approaches and what do
you think it comes out to be that you'd
have to prevent for a time square type
attacks every single day and I thought
square attacks you mean the failed time
square if it had been successful you
have to show that you demonstrate that
you disrupted or deterred or prevent it
or protected against for more than four
attacks per day I do we know how many
DHS is claiming to have prevented or the
government they frankly bring up certain
mysterious things about people have
gotten away we know how many people have
arrested there's maybe 30 or 40 cases
depending on how you sort them out and
I've been through these and most of
these would never in a million years
have been capable of killing very many
people they might potentially dangerous
people but they're not likely being even
on the level of what the times square
bomber would have done why does
government and what is the public for
that matter why do we always
overestimate risk from terrorist
activity lot of the potential costs and
losses of terrorism is giv reaction
where there's lot of indirect issues
where people are people of fade to fly
then that makes you start start driving
the car destinations which is a lot more
dangerous than actual social flying it's
also that people don't really know what
the risk is I mean the chance of using
reasonable analyses your chance of being
killed if you're an American by a
terrorist of any sort Muslim or not is
about 1 in 3.5 million per year
and so the key issue is that's where you
start okay the chances now we're one in
3.5 million per year that sounds pretty
safe do you really want to spend a lot
more money to make it lower mark your
and Australian academic there Australia
has not had the same level of attack on
its own territory but obviously
Australians were one of the main targets
and in various overseas bombings is the
same type of activity going on in
Australia as well yes there's a lotta
concerned about about Homeland Security
and spinning has gone up a lot in
Australia too but in Australia and UK in
Canada spending has gone up by about
half as much as as in the US on a per
capita or pin ggp but is that because
you're only worth half as much they
claim it worth night yeah right so
that's it yeah job what are some of the
things that actually might be done to
reduce threats to national security Oh
terrorist threats i mean if if tsa if
air marshals if things like that are not
effective what are cost effective
remedies well it is a question of
acceptable risk if the if the threat now
if it's a threat it would you even want
to call it a threat if your chance of
being killed by something is one in 3.4
yeah whatever you have like compared to
well i don't know you know well like
your chance being killed by homicide
victim of a homicide we just seem sort
of thrown some you know there's no
benefit it's all right just cost i'm
like it is maybe one in 22,000 your
chance of dying in a bathtub is about
one in a million of them and so
terrorism is one in 3.5 million dying of
cancer is about one or not 500 per year
automobiles about one in a thousand a
year so what are the things that we
might do to to do i mean are there easy
fixes for instance after 911 a lot of
people said merely barricading cockpit
doors essentially ruled out the
possibility of another 911 flight for a
few hundred bucks per plane wellesbourne
net okay but I mean but are there are
there simple fixes like that or is that
just simply the rather simple fixes in
that case is obviously passenger
resistance which comes very cheap maybe
zero cost and so there but our key issue
in this is that all these measures
should be evaluated some of them may be
really quite good and quite
effective cockpit doors are probably one
of them but others are very wasteful and
some are in between well I want to thank
Mark Stewart and John Mueller authors of
Terror security and money balancing
risks benefits and costs of Homeland
Security for talking to reason TV today
gentlemen thank you Tom nick gillespie
you